good evening everybody I it just came to
my attention Brian Collins never heard
of blink-182 why how dear you asked well
I said hey I'm I think I'm gonna go the
blink 182 concert LA this weekend I said
Oh from the book you went oh the book
club yeah high school I was I dropped in
the plot is simple flash simple know
who's playing these drums right I was
Barker bet your sweet old man yeah come
on guys get it you bet your wrinkly ass
ah many times actually don't I'll take
it though you know American Pie I love
when they sing this song oh I will admit
that I genuinely push it to the point
where it's I mean I've last got lights
though never misplace I've missed it
once you got a push and I'm now though
now I realize I'm in Toronto I got to
get to security way too long around our
Fast Pass with that saying sighs then I
got to get through then I gotta get to
customs that is yeah and and I gotta
walk a half mile and I look at it I go
I'm not gonna make it I'm not gonna make
my flight which means let's be stuck in
Toronto got to get home to LA can't have
this can't have this well Toronto so now
I'm sitting there and I'm watching this
this line for special people like I
don't know if they're first-class with
full [ __ ] I don't know if they're
first but no no no sir no that's not
what I mean by God do I I'm sorry no I
don't mean really it's better better
story but no I thought I was like dude I
wouldn't say this on the air no I'd like
you're a nightmare with badges I meant
people with like who look as official
and they're just breezing through the
checkpoint I go you know what I'm not
gonna this is a this is the it's the
kind of line that snakes you know the
one in Vegas well you got a snake who's
sneaking are you nothing we're nothing
worse I'm not sitting in the snake I'm
not standing in the snake this is not
allowed can't have it I'm Brian the kid
Callan and I just
I dropped some laughter on the outer
ones I deserve I deserve a need to give
back I see the guy who's checking
people's things and he turns his back
for a second and I just don't I just
duck under I do a boxing you slipped
woo right oh it's not you no cameras
nothing I just and I got back up and
looked at my ticket like I was like wow
that's where it is yeah my coach ticket
I'm special and I just not first class
either Isis right now listens going yes
is we're taking guns big guy just turned
his back yeah and I walk up and they all
look at me like this and they go what
are you doing and I go I am going
through the line and they go well that's
the line I go well not according to that
guy right there and I point right out of
my god and when they turn the bag on my
flight leaves in 45 minutes
and he goes what guy go that guy right
there told me to come right here I got
to get to my flight and the guy goes we
were ahead and I go whatever you want no
problem go ahead we'll do that I'm just
gonna and I just start taking my stuff
out boom now now customs now I got
another customs issue now with customs
you got to go through the they have a
computer but you have to do a a readout
now I got oh I don't know 25 minutes is
a problem I just walk right to the
customs guy I walk right now
hey man yep think you're Tom because we
do and I go you know what my flight
leaves they told me to come right to you
because who told you I go and that guy
says class it looks at me I look at my
point right at him I'm looking right at
him he looks at me like he doesn't know
what's going on and he goes that guy go
that guy right there I point again that
guy right there told me to come to you
right here come you four-eyes he goes I
don't know what this is
alright what are you here for I go to
and stand up you don't recognize me and
he goes I think I do I go there you go
you're welcome back oh you miss guy the
[ __ ] plane Wow yeah I just made dude
it those water parks are [ __ ] gnarly
man I don't think there's enough safety
at those problem I remember you you know
those things where it's almost like a
wave it's like a reoccurring wave like
people boogie board yes whatever some
cable some you know the wave some kids
way too good at it like he goes to the
park every [ __ ] summer every day and
he's on there showing off why rare
I was in Florida with my dad and brother
and they just put that in my dad though
oh that looks fun we're eating this
long-ass line so this is the way it goes
it has the wave thing we're just
circulant and there's like pros up there
everyone's videotape my like Alex cool
and then it goes spit you out and then
it's a late turns in a lazy river it
goes around the rest of the park blah
blah blah you know like the lazy river
everyone's chillin you go around
everyone alright and my dad's on it he's
pretty good like my dad's an athlete
dude he's gone my god damn wicked dad
gone yeah you'd probably do it my
brother goes he's decent and then I I'm
on the book you offer I don't know maybe
I'm [ __ ] second 1/2 ammo and my
[ __ ] trunk oh my [ __ ] bottoms go
so and then I am funny yeah I'm
butt-naked around the rest of the lazy
river like this [ __ ] in the water
my dad's just like god damn it was like
yeah Lipper Ian Brown lip-read with your
little Willy my dick eight or nine or
eight year old [ __ ] like pro pro some
kid who goes there every [ __ ] summer
for daycare he's killing the game he's
up there for like three minutes a light
comes on to get him off then my dad he's
up there for like two minutes like
goddamn dad big shark eyes doll smile
even does the damn thing why does [ __ ]
up there smiling the whole time then
here's little brown here Joe trunks
these [ __ ] [ __ ] like a Tommy
Hilfiger fake Tommy Hilfiger trunks I
got from Marshalls just just our little
Snickers Barker oh well oiled Snickers
bar I swear to God never gone anything
like that again I was so embarrassed man
what a guy who's just loading up on this
punches coming even if you listen to
Datsuns corner with Jackson and Six Gun
Gibson or six Gibson even they were like
he's just winding up like ducking and
she's doing a thing like I didn't I
didn't watch the decision like I saw I
was a guy it's a easy wind changed the
channel Wow I see on the next morning
Twitter Mike how crazy was that horrible
decision or did you give to linic I'm
like what ya [ __ ] know
yeah it's according to fight metric
Dodson landed 52% of his significance
try
Linacre landed 28% of his do a lot more
I would assume linacre through more yeah
more more aggressive through more all
that stone you didn't know he didn't
throw more he didn't know her I think
did he don't know had to throw more
punches
no no way vinegar no what's the total
strike numbers is that on there like I'm
trying to follow it up right strikes no
no I don't think so huh you might be
right I looking at it I would assume
John through more combos more I felt
like that Lanka was throwing more what
was even a fight what happened to okay
here we go
significant strikes so lineker landed 93
of 322 Dodson landed 101 of 191 so he
was operate so he threw less and landed
that twice as often that's a glazing
they threw less because he threw and
less landed twice as a hundred punches
less right Wow more than 105 is the
judge and scary man
and with those lighter weight classes
most of the time it's can go to the
judges yeah you watch that final I
didn't I didn't think it was a fight
like I thought well in whiskers doing
he's fun to watch he's probably my
favorite fighter to watch on the weight
class by far yeah
but as far as winning that fight night
in close right eye I didn't think it was
remotely I think things much of a fight
mmm that's in it crazy yeah crazy Mary's
crazy
Gonzaga kicked me swear at squaring the
nut Oh grand the nuts and it hurts but
you feel pressure from the crowd to keep
fighting yeah I'm good but actually
really really hurts in a [ __ ] your fight
like you think about if you well people
have trained or if anything we need to
hit in the nuts in a [ __ ] your whole
game up like you start to feel sick so
you see a lot of guys like lineker got
kicked in the nuts you see dots and
jumps on them right away like a lot of
guys know when you get kicked in the
nuts there's a time to pounce on them
yeah that's the time to do it so it's an
advantage I personally think if the guy
gets him the nuts hard enough they
should probably get outcome of a fight
you'll see some guys they kick in the
nuts and then they get super emotional
start swinging it'll [ __ ] a fight do you
feel it later no right away
no I'm saying oh the winger not really
right not really
okay [ __ ] your day up though yeah or 900
it's that time again we got a bonus
podcast because we got Aubrey Marcus the
CEO and on on it owner RB we usually use
Magic Man as an icon yeah we opened with
or just friend so about a month ago I
had this trip booked but I didn't have
all the dates that out and I wake up
from this dream and in the dream this
demon comes to me like really visible
visceral demon comes to me and says I'm
gonna kill you on September 23rd and
then boom I wake up it was like that was
[ __ ] gnarly it's nothing subtle about
that he's like 4 in the morning I'm
going to kill you on September 23rd so
it's 4:00 in the morning I click open my
phone I look at the dates of the trip
and that's the night that we have
scheduled for ayahuasca now maybe
somewhere in my mind I knew that but I
wouldn't have been able to recite that I
was like ah somewhere 21st through 27
anyways that's the night we were
planning to do ayahuasca so I'm like oh
[ __ ] this is gonna be a big one
so knowing that going through I was kind
of preparing but some of it was just I
was thinking maybe I was just a dream
right so we go to drink the medicine in
ayahuasca is this psychedelic tea that
they've been serving for a thousand
years DMT based orally active hot tea
and that's not hot but it's spicy as
[ __ ] it's like you're literally drinking
the jungle I actually have a documentary
on website drink the jungle calm drink
in the jungle you [ __ ] up yeah drink
the jungle
so anyways good that's a good yeah so so
anyways I drink the tea in and pretty
much 30 minutes in they start singing
ocurro's you know
yeah you guys have heard those and so
they start singing the eager oohs and it
starts off super mellow and I see them
seeing flowers and I'm seeing the jungle
but I'm feeling like what feels like
what I call the little doctors which is
like little pieces of light that seem to
be fixing different parts of my head and
heart they like come through and they
like almost like rewiring the circuits
is what it feels like in my head so I'm
feeling that and I hear this voice like
oh man just chill it's just a dream
don't worry about it I was like oh
awesome I start having really cool
visions like the first vision I had was
this monument of this monkey and then
the words written in like inscribed in
the stone it says we are the pleasure
monkeys sounds like oh yeah that's kind
of cool that's really what we are we're
[ __ ] pledges we're here to like enjoy
sex and smile and laugh like so I was
able to like identify this body in the
thing it's like alright I'm a pleasure
monkey like I'm cool with that great
t-shirt yeah so anyways so you know go
through the pleasure monkey but still
it's fixing that and I'm thinking man
this is gonna be chill I'm an hour in
there's only another couple hours to go
and then boom like right out of my left
hand side and I'm gonna first let me say
a caveat I'm not a religious guy but
there's some religious kind of context
to this that just kind of came up and
you know a lot of this and don't read
into it too much this is just my vision
so anyway so this demon comes to me from
my left-hand side and it's like this
gnarly Gollum looking like like a little
thief ugly nasty little demon like no no
you'd like bald head and like little
vampire demon a little [ __ ] head it's
like a little [ __ ] demon you know
Smeagol
Smeagol II very schmegle right yeah but
it's compared to the other visions which
was like kind of pastel II and very
ephemeral this is like there's a [ __ ]
demon right there
so I identify it and and I I've learned
through my battles that you don't fight
these guys you just send them love you
recognize them being part of
consciousness part of the duality of all
things that are life light and dark
necessary to create the cosmos necessary
to allow free will because without
resistance we would just escalate to
enlightenment immediately
everything would be easy the game would
be boring it be like a video game
without monsters so the best way to
treat these demons is to send them love
be like hey man like here you are I see
you I love you you know I appreciate the
fact that you're holding down that
polarity for all of consciousness go on
as you're having this vision where were
you sitting what do you think you're
body lying I'm lying down just in the
woods or what the jungle sounds are all
around
look arose yeah there's 18 people there
but they're all tripping balls all
tripping in their own in their own
experience unlock this ayahuasca shijou
you know what's crazy like meanwhile the
shamans almost never purged they don't
ever puke but as soon as I started
interacting with these dark forces like
they're kind of controlling the energy
of the room they were just puking their
guts out damn yeah like they were like
they were doing as well they were they
were helping me with this energy that
was moving through right so I knew it
was gnarly and I kept trying to send
them messages like it's gonna be alright
like you cans gonna be cool in your mind
right like I got this like we're gonna
be okay but anyway so I dissolve the red
stone and I'm like [ __ ] this is so
gnarly and I was like man like can I
like at least see like see like a Jesus
or something like that little light that
there was like a moment of like a moment
of respite where I saw Jesus come in and
Jesus met that dark force who could be
the devil and again I'm using Christian
terms like so like all of the light
meets all of the dark and they
immediately turn into gay lovers and I
got like I got like a chance like laughs
you know and be like oh okay that that
makes sense you know of course they love
back a little bro all of this from all
of the light of course loves all of the
dark you know it's that it's the perfect
balance it's the yin and yang of the
cosmos right and and still though I'm
I'm just sitting there kind of unsure
and and and I got a little bit laugh out
of it and I can still feel the pull of
of darkness and I just kind of surrender
deeper to just love and fake and then I
felt this I felt something really cool
happened and I felt this like
breastplate come like slap on my chest
boom and this big like Fire Opal gem
right in my heart
soon as that hit me I like just
completely relaxed and I felt light like
super light and then I could feel wings
like [ __ ] coming out of my back and then
all of a sudden I was flying like with
all the Eagles and angels your world
roll now yeah and it was [ __ ] amazing
we are here to maximize our own
enjoyment where pleasure monkeys
maximize your pleasure
oh sweet pleasure monkey and maximize
the pleasure of everyone else around you
of the whole earth like everybody who's
in existence like make the whole game
more fun you know like it ain't no fun
if the homies don't have none ya know
like that's that's really what it's all
about and that gets summed up in Peru
you say para el bien de todos for the
good of all and then when you really do
that you can empty yourself of all the
ego and really forgive yourself and not
try to make it all about you and what
you're gonna do and what you're going to
accomplish like how can you feel the
most pleasure because you deserve to
feel the most pleasure how can you help
everybody else feel the most because
we're all [ __ ] up I'm [ __ ] up I'm
ignorant Lee shocked at how ignorant how
quickly I forget the lessons I learned
but it's also I've learned to forgive
myself fast and not belabor these things
and just recognize that no matter all of
the failings that I've had no matter how
stupid I was when I was younger it's all
part of life it's all part or the
failures the failings you have may not
be feelings it may be part of a mindset
that makes you better at something else
so sometimes you might be bad at this
but that's precisely why you're good at
something else so it's another way to
look at things yeah it's just part it's
just part of the game you know and then
realizing that I'm here as a force for
the good of all how can I do that the
best job that I get the UC 204 coming up
this weekend and how Bisbing would get
it get it done or how Hendo would get it
done and Perillo hookup came out today
and said that Bisbing is gonna beat him
via left head kick well and I love Perl
I think he's one of the best coaches in
the business but if because he's not
known for knocking guys out via head
kick so if that is your secret weapon
well you just told everybody and it's
Dan Henderson you don't think he's ever
seen a left high kick before and if
anyone's gonna get kicked in the head is
coming Bisbing you can't see out of his
eye for God's sakes
and he's been knocked out how many times
by
psychic vitor belfort Rockhold like
that's his MO can him go get that leg up
there lombard yeah spinning that's
spinning how about that's how we
finished him it's a vision but he he had
kicked him I mean he really caught more
guys known for it I mean it's a bold
claim I love that coach he's probably
the best guy in the business right now
but that is that is bold men ladies and
gentlemen the man meter and the sports
meter just hit red-hot so happy jealous
walks in all six-foot-two says he's six
two I'm giving him six three six
symmetry and starring now in insecure
we're gonna get into all that well I
think if I had to choose when I take
Westbrook over Durant would you yes if I
had if take LeBron of the equation if I
had like a draft if I was a president of
a basketball team I would take why
Russell Westbrook I like his passion no
one can guard him he can shoot the
lights out I think he'll be better
without what without Durant because
there's only so many basketball that go
around so when and and I also think you
have something to prove now he's a chip
on the shoulder like oh you guys think
it's over because Brent laughs I just
happen to be one of the top three best
players in the league check this out you
know what I like about him he looks like
he might slap one of his teammates he
looks like he's always mad like
seriously like and that's what I like
about him like he looks like the
ultimate competitor and there's very I
felt like there's those guys compete but
I feel like there's very few guys who
who don't care about what the image is
and they just want to play they just
want to win like Opie like like Kobe
said Russell Westbrook is the closest
thing that he's ever seen to him they
were so Kobe's already in the NBA
Russell was in high school and got to
play one-on-one with Kobe when Kobe was
like oh my god he was going his fence
like he you know when you ever watch
those old clips of Jordan when he was
really uncommon out of like North
Carolina and you see how he would move
and you go he's just a step fast he'd
get called for traveling a lot because
he was just so fast like the refs had
never seen a baby I feel like was
Russell Westbrook as an athlete just
athletically is that
explosive have you seen his workouts to
their nuts like Kobe and Redondo on the
sand and just doing work like he's
relent I don't want to watch him I'd
probably throw up no it's great for him
like day there was a documentary I was
in a huge Kevin Durant fan I saw this
documentary I think it was on HBO maybe
as a documentary on Kevin Durant the
last not this year the year before when
they lost since going that offseason
they show his work I think they show him
in Oklahoma City doing all this stuff
and then he called her Durant's blowing
up his phone to come train with him
means I come around these hills with me
and he's like he gets them there and you
know Westbrook just doing work doesn't
care about the camera it's just like you
said think about the image this doing so
I think by Kevin Durant leaving I think
the Thunder will be better people
disagree with that there was this kid
who used to come play open gym in the
summers his mom was a Booker for a
modeling agency they needed a bunch of
extras for something I went and did it I
started talking to this chick I was
trying to hit on her she wasn't really
happening she was literally looking
straight past me but she started telling
this story about how she just got back
from Asia and she was there for like
three months and she made 30 grand and
everything was paid for and I was like
yo did you have crack up here at like
what's going on so I was like oh that's
that's what I need to do with my life
like I moved I'm gonna do that I'm gonna
be a male mom I'm just gonna do that I
don't even know what that means but I'm
gonna do that yeah yeah bleep a
massively good-looking guy but you know
what here's what ended up happening Nike
is based in Portland Columbia Sports
were based in Portland adidas us is
based in Portland it was one of those
towns were like if you were athletic you
could you could you can make a little
money
mm-hmm this is what it was because Nike
used so many people from Portland when
they weren't using athletes yes they
used so many models from Portland and
most of them played at Portland State
they played at U P they played at
Concordia where I ended up graduating
they played at Lewis and Clark they
painted all these like small schools
whether it's basketball football
baseball track whatever and they had
these great athletic bodies and so
Adidas Nike and Columbia Sportswear
we're constantly using these people and
to interrupt you for a second I think
the Nike store for a while
actually using real athletes yes as
their salespeople you walk in and be
like well you look like you do you know
you're a professional so you're the
first gig that you booked was with Nike
Nike was I'll early so I went in I met
that girl on a Friday on Monday morning
at like 10 o'clock I put on the best
outfit that I had which was like
basically this like horrible suit that I
like wore when I graduated from high
school man it was so big and boxy but I
thought I was like this I thought I was
the sexiest dude on the I cut my own
hair but but I went in there shooting I
took Polaroids they circulated I don't
know what they did with the Polaroid
that was that like he 11 o'clock in the
morning at 5 o'clock that same day they
called me and told me that I had booked
a Jordan catalog watch Jordan and I was
like yo lord I don't even know what this
means
that's a basketball player go Jordan oh
yeah like I was just like do I get free
stuff I didn't care about the money I
get 11 skin do I get new 11th yeah yeah
and it was right when they were starting
to recirculate the Jays too so it was
also like it was in that time period
were like they were starting to go back
and like do all the retros right they
were starting to do the eights they were
7 this was like prop probably this was
definitely after the patent leather face
because they were starting to do patent
in all the different colors they didn't
the baby blue they was doing in the
great money and so did you was it real
money but your friends like especially
back then if I went from football to
modeling my friends might what's wrong
with you I didn't tell anybody just
there's like damn poster of Michael
Jordan killing my cousin who plays
football at oh you his name is Jordan
who's this dude has literally twice
caught me cuz this didn't happen to give
when I started acting I didn't why this
is now twice that's caught me so my he
would get dropped off at the mall on on
the weekend there's nothing else to do
so like you know Saturday you go to the
mall with your girlfriend and you just
walk around all day long right so he
walked into foot action and I'm hanging
up in foot action and he tells my mom I
saw Jay and foot action and she's like
nah he's goes to school in Oregon and
she's like no he's like no I saw him in
a picture
hanging a foot action and she's like oh
whatever
so the next weekend they're all at my
whole family's at the mall again Jordan
takes my mom into the foot action and
sees me hanging up in foot action and
she calls me and she's like why are you
hanging a foot action I'm sorry I didn't
know where they put these things not
just winning care about that I just
wanted the cash so I just went in shot
and then love went back to class went to
practice why are you hanging a foot
action I was like what you mean and she
was like it's supposed are you hanging a
foot action I asked the manager for but
he told me I can't have it to the end of
the month but I told him I'm your mama
so I should be able to take it now and I
don't think it works I don't think you
can boss the manager a foot action
around but I don't know but now it is
hanging in her house actually for sure
of course I think in the back of my mind
I think I always had this unstated thing
like thought that like the modeling will
get me closer to acting couldn't be
further from the truth really I like
this totally different worlds like
couldn't be couldn't be forever even
talk to each other nothing I don't even
talk to each other unless you're a
massive models gonna say there's a few
that they'll make the transition but not
many like that's the except I'm even
then you jump into a whole different
group yeah so it just it wasn't that so
like I left I moved to LA I got here and
I was like yo somebody is gonna call me
I'm about to get a show like I thought
somebody's just gonna like literally
pull me off the streets of like Beverly
Hills and be like hey where you been man
we got a show for you come on we got to
get you a brew CBS rapper because we got
to do it you know we got a we got a
chemistry read you what a bunch of girls
you got to make out a bunch of girl so
we can see who your girl on the show is
gonna be like I literally thought that
somebody was just going to give me a
show of course man all right so I get a
part-time job I get it I get some job I
was I was working at Sports Club LA
which is now Equinox directly below
endeavor before it was W me yep so I was
like agents coming here every single day
so it agents gonna come in here at 5
o'clock in the morning I'm gonna give
him his towel he's gonna like the way I
gave him his towel he's gonna say hey
kid
go in my office come see me [ __ ] didn't
happen so I got tired of working at five
o'clock in the morning so I got a
part-time job working retail did that
for a few years and then I went to
school with this kid I grew up with this
kid named Josh Henderson who's an actor
who at the time was dating this very
famous girl and they threw this big
party at the CBS rad for a lot further
for the girl and so I was wasted like
super super drunk and I was standing
there talking to a couple people telling
them what it's like to live in a model
house with 13 dudes and this agent walks
up to me and he's like hey are you an
actor and I'm like yeah never took
acting class never took a headshot had
no idea what acting like I wanted to do
it but never know what and I was like
yeah I'm acting he's like cool I want
you to come to my office next week you
know bring your headshot bring your
resume let's sit down and talk all right
cool so fast-forward I take it my
modeling book because I didn't know what
a headshot was I type up every modeling
job I had every single ad I had ever had
and like I reach across the desk and I
hand it to him and he looks at me he
goes you have no idea what the hell
you're doing do you and I go no but I
swear to God if you just give me a
minute I'll figure it out like just give
me a few months like I'll get in class
I'll get headshots whatever ever stage
whatever it takes right I was like yeah
I'm gonna compete like that was my that
was my video first and we do have the
main character they do their best I'm
just saying that when you're when you're
a white man or you're gonna write from
your exposure experience it's very
difficult for you to even be and and it
might even be embarrassing for you to
try to write for what a black or a
Latina or an Asian person shows through
on a daily basis right and that that's
what I was talking about forget who we
had in there buzz three white guys
talking about what we do Bob Saget Oh
Bob Saget use three white guys talk
about what we do with you know you see
the shootings the the the cop relations
all that stuff and the three of us three
white guys given our viewpoints on it I
by wish it liked it that it's not that
I'm sick of hearing it it's not that we
didn't have valid points but that I
think we need to hear from an
african-american who stood their
viewpoint like so much from that side
and speak out right the white guys can
talk all day like you look on CNN and
that's what bothers me most
look at CNN yes these rich white guys
they have no clue what it's like
literally no clue and they're just
breaking down their opinion you never
see it from the other side and I think
you're right so like you know the
biggest thing is like is the behind the
camera in this case right like you have
to diversify your writers room because
you're right you can't be I don't think
you can have a writers room full of
white men and women writing about a
Latino a black or an Asian experience I
actually don't even think you can do it
for one character on a show well I think
you have to have diversity in your
writers rooms because I think that helps
tell a I think it helps it helps make
sure that that character's voice is
authentic but I actually think it helps
the story overall be more often because
everybody's represented and there's
you're not going to you're not gonna say
something that you don't realize is
offensive or would never be said or just
isn't true Tory isn't even organic
disorder yet to the story I feel like
it's being shoehorn in there yeah and
and see I think it's about letting they
think that's why yeah I'm saying like
they think that's how they're supposed
to access I think that's what they would
say so why not just bring someone in who
actually knows would do it if it were
the tech world yeah literally how you
would get someone who has Silicon Valley
experience and bring them in to consult
you know what I mean - make sure the
language was right in a fighter they
usually talk to a fighter or whatever a
bodybuilder an athlete if the if the
characters an athlete say what would you
have done in this how would you have
broken this down you know I'm saying I
think money's gonna dictate this I think
as you start to see a growing safe just
as example a growing black middle-class
right with more disposable income
they're going to want to experience on
the screen what they have experienced
something they can identify what's gonna
happen is see if this [ __ ] doesn't
happen with mandates it doesn't happen
because people are politically correct
doesn't it shouldn't happen for any of
those reasons I think that's all
[ __ ] because I frankly I don't think
the majority of people in Hollywood are
racist or prejudiced I think they just
didn't don't even know how to fix the
problem what I think is gonna have a
conscious of it day I think so I think
most people have a sense of fairview a
and they feel what do you think well let
me finish this point what I'm saying is
that I think what's gonna happen and
what is happening and your your show is
an exam
is that they're gonna go you know we got
a whole market that's being ignored and
we have some pretty talented writers out
here and let's start tapping into those
people and by the way you can find them
on YouTube you can find them here and
that's what's great about the free
market look at Tyler Perry I agree with
that good Tyler Perry he's like do what
I'm just gonna start my own [ __ ] I'm
good right the male version of Oprah you
know what I'm gonna do this in Atlanta
you know what I think it is I think that
like the the need for diversity has been
acknowledged I think in Hollywood right
but I think you're right it hasn't
necessarily been addressed properly and
I think like you said it's tapping into
writers of color and whether it's
bringing them onto projects whether it's
helping them create their own projects
and get their own projects made so I
think it's that but I went through right
before I book right before I booked this
I went through pilot season and Empire
just come out and Empire was a massive
hit huge so every network was like we
need to have a black show we need a
black show people on our shows we need a
project and and completely reactive
right I like it straight following right
and so what you ended up seeing was all
these scripts that were never the
diversity was just never thought about
you end up seeing them like well that
person has to be black now what that
person has to be agent now where that
person has to be this now and they were
shoehorn it they were trying to make
something more [ __ ] that wasn't real
right and so you ended up with a I don't
know if any shows actually survived from
that pilot season you have with you
ended up with shows like literally I
can't think of shows that acted because
black black is but no that actually came
out that same year blackish was a
midseason show that same year because
you know what Empire does Empire work
from character first from people right
like like the struggle island that would
but think about the people that were
casted oh yeah yeah she's amazing Rosie
Rush is amazing she's on another level
but what but it's not just the talent it
was also that that script and that pilot
and that show was written first with the
notion that these are human beings going
through going through what you
said going through the same things that
everybody goes through with the same
aspirations the same flaws really that's
a Greek that's a Greek tragedy that's a
Shakespearean tragedy Empire and that
was it and that cuts across all cultures
so they didn't start there what what the
network's did that copied that was they
went they I start because I read some of
the scripts and they came out and they
go well we got to be diverse let's let's
copy this here's the blueprint and it's
all and we'll just put this it's not
organic it's not tried at all yeah and
so you see you come up with a bunch of
shows that you know probably weren't
successful for that reason pretty and
get picked up for that reason or who
didn't make it out of you know a few
episodes or their first season for that
reason I think you also what ends up
happening I think in a situation like
that is you end up with a base of actors
that then become pissed about it because
they didn't get a job because a show
needed to be diverse that's right and
then you also end up with that so then
there's this weird thing of like this
weird I don't want to say backlash but
there's definitely you know I think
there's resentment there's there's
there's sometimes resentment but on both
sides rights cuz of you nobody wants to
get a job because they were Asian or I
mean do you wanna get a job on the on
your merits yeah you always wanted to
get a job on your errands I don't think
anybody wants to get a job purely just
because of their race for somebody's
better actor and I got the job because I
you know that yeah that doesn't feel
that good for sometimes it works yeah
well sometimes I'm sure we're talking
about is fair play
I think we're talking about representing
the demographic that's out there that's
watching us so and I think that's only
gonna get more inclusive absolutely I
felt that I felt like that show blackish
I think if they came out with a show
whitish orexin is right I don't saying
like Chinese is